now we have leon messi yeah this is the
new
uh or the latest iteration of
chess 24.
uh we have gm
leon luke mandonka from india another
very strong
young player i don't think he's quite as
good as uh as prague but certainly very
talented as well and he's from from team
kramnik
so
we're just gonna get it going
and uh vary the openings obviously
oh c6 he does the
weird move order for
for the slav the only worry about this
one is that bishop
f4 is possible but i'm sure he has
something prepared here
and here the trick is knight e4
queen c2
if queen d4 there's e3
so apparently this is the way the people
play
and wish i knew how to play against it
but i don't
e3 there's bishop f5
how does that work
bishop d3
uh
d4 s
c dc4 bishop e4
bishop b4 net queen a4 queen b2
he wins the rook but i may trap his
queen
it probably doesn't work okay let's go
f3 first
i should know these lines but
unfortunately i don't
unfortunately the idiots in the back are
not here today
so
if there
are any problems with the stream quality
that's them
that's the issue
okay interesting
queen a5 so i guess i'll go knight d2
and he'll probably exchange
or maybe it will go back
um
thinking that
knight d2 is uh it's a concession
who knows
yeah let's have some fun castle
queenside
this probably isn't very good
but
then again
where's the fun in playing good moves
oh 97 i'm not convinced about
probably should take on
d5 actually
yeah i think i'll do that
i was thinking if
if uh e4 then fd4 fe4 e5
um
but now
if d4 fe4 e5 i get the c4 square for my
bishop and that should give me some
extra opportunities
now i think we'll just develop
if he wants to go d4
fe4
take on d4 be my guest i'm fine with
that but i think he would just lose way
too much time
with development
yeah i see the mods are are working now
is there always so much spam or is it
just that i'm
usually not paying attention to chat
i think there probably is
anyway now
i think he has to develop with with uh
g6
uh
but
his position feels
um
feels a bit
fishy
i think i'll just go e5 actually i don't
think i can break through in the center
and uh e5
as soon as i can sort of get the king
away from
the file this will just give me a
positional edge
and he's spending way too much time here
okay now i think i'll go f4 f5 if it
castled there that would have been
pretty much suicide due to
um
due to uh to f5 uh sorry h for h5
okay so he has found an idea here which
is a little bit annoying
in that he wants to go
he wants to go for e6 after
after um
i'm of the rook but i don't think
there's anything i can do about it
so i'll just play positionally if i give
a check
are there any tricks
i think there probably are
yeah let's try
probably should just go king of f8 yeah
i was hoping for a knight d7 and i had
some sick tricks there
but now you should just run the king
after i spent that much time i'll
probably
probably have to flag another game here
hopefully i will be winning a position
by the time that i i hopefully get to
fly game
queen of three
this i think improved my position quite
a bit
uh
okay this was a bit unfortunate
he exchanges
i will go bishop b4
restricting his pieces
queen f3 let's get that bishop in there
win a pawn
oh he just okay i'll trade that's fine
bishop goes away
we'll just trade that
king c5 next oh he's fighting well
fighting really well
i guess the all the young dudes do that
but now
he's got no chance
i got way too much time here
i don't have auto queen that's
unfortunate